okay guys it is somehow the second half
of March already my name is Jeff and
here's the things that mattered in the
world of gaming today I know most you
guys hate dishing out for a cosmetic
upgrade but Microsoft have announced a
couple of new controllers that look very
very pretty and a lot of you seem to
think so too the copper Shadow Xbox one
controller will be sold at Gamestop and
Microsoft stores while the dusk shadow
one will be available at Best Buy as
well as the Microsoft Store both will
sell for 70 bucks when they hit shelves
later this year each controller has a
sweet gradient metallic finish and if
you're already into it pre-orders are
open now like your standard Xbox one
controller things are wireless and come
with two double-a batteries things are
looking pretty good for the possibility
that the Xbox one and ps4 networks may
be connected because neither company
wants to be the one thing no we won't do
it
president of Sony Computer Entertainment
worldwide studios Shuhei Yoshida has
responded to Microsoft's invitations to
connect Xbox Live and PlayStation
Network
he told Eurogamer that Sony has
supported cross-platform play between
PlayStation consoles and PC for a number
of games including rocket league and
Street Fighter 5 and that the technical
challenges of connecting the networks
could be the easiest to overcome that
said he explained we also have to look
at policy issues and business issues as
well
Yoshida said he is happy to have the
conversation about cross-platform play
with any publishers or developers so
fingers crossed finally three new Xbox
one backwards compatible games have been
revealed the new additions are Alan Wake
pac-man and Castlevania Symphony of the
Night if you own these games digitally
you'll be able to download them again
for free via the Xbox ones ready to
download section should you find
yourself with Alan Wake on disc you can
also pop that in your Xbox one which
will subsequently download the files to
make it work on your current gen console
the Xbox one backwards compatibility
library is now over
hundred and thirty-four games strong and
chicken check them all out in our story
on GameSpot Microsoft had previously
confirmed that Dark Souls is also on its
way to becoming a backwards-compatible
titles let me know down in that comment
section which of these backwards
compatible titles you're most excited to
play you can also head to GameSpot we've
got stories on Star Wars Battlefront dlc
and the next free EA PC game that's
everything I have you today but let me
know what you thought about today's
stories and pop-by same time tomorrow
for the best stories of the entire week
I was feeling